[Music]
Well done, we have defeated the Demon King.
Now, an era of peace will come to the world.
[Music]
This is the end of our adventure. It's
been 10 years, isn't it?
A lot has happened, hasn't it?
It's a 10-year adventure.
50 or 100 years may be trivial to her.
Defeating the Demon King doesn't mean it's over. You have a much
longer life ahead of
you.  Life
will be longer than we can even imagine.
[Music] I'm glad I had the chance to go on an
adventure with you. I
knew that human life was short, but you
're still a kind child. You're the flower of my hometown.  You're so
beautiful, I
bet you didn't think I was an amateur
[Music] I
want to show it to you someday
[Music] Well then, let
's go